billion parameters running on a machine
that costs less than one [music] cooling
fan from an H100 GPU. Not a Temu
knockoff either. GLM 5.2, an open model
that sits above Claude Opus in the
latest LLM Arena benchmarks, answering
correctly from a laptop with 25 GB of
RAM. The model is 15 times bigger than
the memory it's running in. [music]
The engine pulling this off is called
Colibri, 1,300 lines of C. No Python, no
GPU, and the loophole it exploits is
hiding inside every big AI model you've
used this year. By the end of this
video, you'll know exactly how a model
that can't fit in your computer runs on
it anyway, and why the number everyone's
laughing at is the wrong thing to look
at. Try and wrap your mind around it.
>> [music]
>> GLM 5.2's weights, compressed down to 4
bits per number, take up 370 GB.
>> [music]
>> You'd normally need half a data center
of GPUs lying around. Call it $40,000 or
a Mac Studio with 256
gigs of unified memory. Anything less
and the model refuses to load. The
obvious workaround is reading the model
straight off the SSD instead. For a
normal model, that idea is dead on
arrival. Every parameter is needed for
every single token, so you'd be pulling
all 370 GB off the disk for [music]
every word. On the fastest consumer SSD
money can buy, that's almost half a
minute per word. Good luck writing your
code like that. So, why does Colibri
work? Because GLM 5.2 is not built like
a normal model. GLM 5.2 is a mixture of
experts model. Inside each layer,
instead of one giant block of neurons,
there are 256
smaller ones called experts. In front of
them sits a tiny [music] piece of the
network called the router. Every time a
token comes through, the router scores
all 256 experts and picks the eight best
suited for that exact token at that
exact layer. The other 248 stay asleep.
Now, take experts with a grain of salt.
People picture a math guy, a code guy, a
poetry guy, and figure you could keep
the code guy and delete the rest.
Experts are really unlabelled blobs of
learned weights with messy, overlapping
jobs,
>> [music]
>> and the router's choice changes token by
token, layer by layer. The same word
[music] gets different experts in a
different sentence. There is no coding
subset to keep. Add it up, and out of
billion parameters, only about 40
billion do any work per token,
>> [music]
>> around 5%. The rest of the model is, at
any given moment, that weight, and that
weight doesn't need to be in RAM. That's
the concept Colibri rides on. Split the
model [music] into the parts every token
touches, the attention layers, the
embeddings, one shared [music] expert,
add up to just under 10 GB at 4-bit
precision. Those get pinned in RAM
permanently. The other 21 and 1/2
thousand experts, 19 MB a piece, sit in
a 370 [music]
GB file on the SSD. Then, for every
token, the dense core in RAM does its
work, and the router names its eight
experts for this layer. Colibri checks a
cache [music] it keeps in the spare RAM.
Already loaded, multiply and move on.
Missing, the engine reads that exact
expert off the SSD at its exact [music]
byte offset, multiplies, and evicts
whichever expert has gone unused
longest. Repeated across all 75 layers,
and [music] the next token starts the
cycle over. A fully cold token touches
about 11 GB of disk reads. That's
insane,
>> [music]
>> but routing is cute. A small crowd of
favorite experts handles most of the
traffic, so Colibri keeps a usage log on
disk. And on the next launch, it pins
your personal hot experts into whatever
RAM is left over. The engine measurably
gets faster the more you use it. Of
course, there was pushback when this
released. Llama.cpp can already memory
map a model bigger than your RAM. True,
but memory mapping is the operating
system guessing. It faults pages in
blind, one small read at a time,
blocking the whole thread while it
waits, with no idea which weights are
important. Colibri knows. The moment the
router picks its eight experts, [music]
the engine requests all of them from the
disk at once, asynchronously, while the
CPU keeps crunching. [music]
It even runs the next layer's router
early on partial information, so experts
are loading before they're needed. A
page fault can't see the future. A
router [music] can, a little.
You're all waiting on the catch, right?
On the author's laptop, this runs at a
tenth of a token per second. A 500 token
answer [music] takes an hour and a half.
The community benchmarked up the
hardware ladder. A budget SSD gets
[music] you .1 tokens per second. A top
PCIe 5 drive, .28. A 128 gig Framework
laptop, .37.
And an M5 [music] Max with a monster
internal SSD tops the chart at one token
per second. That's the ceiling today.
>> [music]
>> And no, this won't kill your SSD.
Streaming is pure reads, and reads don't
wear out flash.
>> [music]
>> Writes do. The real risk is a cheap
drive thermally throttling after hours
of running flat out. So, given the
speed, is it useless then?
>> [music]
>> Depends what you're counting. A tenth of
a token per second is also 8,000 tokens
a day. Several long frontier quality
answers every day from a laptop with no
internet connection. Grandpa still
remembers running a PC overnight to
download movies. Now, they can generate
the answers instead. If this were one
weird repo, it would be a party trick.
There's more. [music]
The same season, antirez, the guy who
wrote Redis, shipped DS4, a metal and C
engine that streams deep six experts off
a MacBook's SSD. Llama CPP has open
proposals for exactly this kind of
expert cash, and vLLM is catching its
own version. Serious runtimes are
starting to treat the SSD as a memory
tier instead of a filing cabinet. The
great unlock everyone's eyeing is
prediction. Colibri already guesses the
next layer's experts with 72% [music]
accuracy. Every point that number
climbs, more discrete finish in the
background before anyone's waiting on
them. If routing turns out to be mostly
predictable, the disk penalty largely
evaporates, and streaming starts to feel
like running the model for real.
Should you run this? Well, not for a
back and forth on your day job. In that
case, just grab the biggest model that
fits in your fast memory and enjoy your
60 tokens per second. Colibri is for
jobs where quality outranks the clock.
Overnight refactors, air-gapped
machines, work that legally can't leave
the building. The bigger point survives
either way. For the price of one
consumer SSD, the floor for touching a
frontier model dropped out of the data
center and [music] onto a desk.